stealing out of sheer desperation after
a devastating earthquake is something
Cesar sonmez can empathize with he's
been living in a tent with his family
after his home was damaged
the shoe store owner estimates nearly 7
000 pairs of shoes were stolen
his pleas to the looters to only take
what they needed were ignored yet he
speaks with an aura of calm
we have so many brothers who have died I
live with the pain inside of me I'm
ready to do whatever I can I have no
other option but to be calm this is in
our culture as a country we can
understand people
the commercial District in the ancient
city of antakya was deserted on Sunday
but for business owners and employees
salvaging what they could by the handful
often endangering themselves by entering
the hulks of structurally unsound
buildings many are homeless and in
mourning everyone seems to know not just
one but dozens of people who have died
when I see other shops I thank God other
places are worse as people have lost
their lives we can fix our businesses
and continue may God help everyone
thousands of trucks full of humanitarian
Aid have been dispatched to the southern
provinces there have been some instances
of that Aid being stolen 57 people have
been arrested according to the ministry
of Justice President erdogan says
looters anyone who engages in corruption
or capitalizes on this catastrophe will
be punished and this is why he declared
a three-month state of emergency in the
earthquake zone now the people here say
they expect the government to honor its
pledges to rebuild their diverse City
and hope Aid will be distributed equally
we are living together like brothers and
sisters this is a city of civilizations
we are used to living like this and we
don't want the government to
discriminate with regards to the
situation people are being asked to
evacuate but those we spoke to say with
so many people they know still buried
beneath the rubble they can't leave just
yet Natasha name Al Jazeera antakia
turquia